business inclusivo
se non sapete cos'è va molto bene è
tutto molto in regola e io ho dieci
minuti e in questi dieci minuti sarei
molto contenta se vi arrivassero due
concetti fondamentali il primo è che se
voi fate sviluppo sostenibile
non ci sono delle appartenenze
prestabilite cioè dei ruoli immutabili
che non possono cambiare per cui se tu
vieni da una certa estrazione sociale o
da una certa tradizione lavorativa
dovrai sempre per forza fare quella cosa
lì la seconda cosa è che esiste un
enorme potenziale dato dall'incontro fra
realtà completamente diverse
ed è un potenziale che vale la pena di
esplorare perché è portatore di crescita
di sviluppo
fare business inclusivo segni
sentite più
adesso molto bene allora incomincio fare
e fare business inclusivo significa
pensare a come produrre dei beni o dei
servizi coinvolgendo direttamente
comunità a basso reddito quindi
riuscendo a rispondere a delle necessità
dei bisogni di queste comunità nei loro
territori quindi nove volte su dieci
stiamo parlando di paesi in via di
sviluppo però non è sempre la regola
quindi vi chiederete come si fa a
coinvolgere queste comunità all'interno
della catena di creazione del valore
aggiunto da una prospettiva
imprenditoriale quindi facendo business
beh ci sono due alternative la prima è
considerarli dei clienti
cosa che però
non dà sempre buoni risultati e spesso
incontra resistenze proprio da parte di
queste comunità
la seconda è come produttori quindi qui
l'innovatività della visione di business
inclusivo cioè pensare a queste comunità
come se fossero dei co partner di
impresa andando quindi a
valorizzare il loro ruolo culturale e il
loro portato innovativo che di solito si
traduce in innovazione tecnologica e
nuove reti di distribuzione
adesso non concentriamoci troppo sulla
definizione di comunità a basso reddito
perché in realtà non esiste una
definizione unica universale che si dia
un'idea di chi stiamo parlando perché
sono realtà molto diversificate
piuttosto possiamo pensare di seguire
l'approccio che ci suggerisce a marty ha
sempre mio nome per l'economia nel 98
che ci dice che queste persone sono
persone che vivono in economia informali
cioè economie non tracciate che
subiscono forti distorsioni interne e
persone a cui mancano delle opportunità
cioè persone che non sono in grado di
manifestare il proprio potenziale la
propria capacità
ora che cosa c'è in tutto questo di
lateral thinking motivo per cui siamo
qui oggi c'è che qui noi non stiamo
parlando di un impresa che va a
delocalizzare in un paese in via di
sviluppo per ridurre sui costi di
manodopera e non stiamo neanche parlando
di 1 ng o di una onlus che fa
beneficenza un progetto di volontariato
nei paesi in via di sviluppo
qui noi parliamo di core business cioè
un impresa sta in piedi facendo business
inclusivo il tutto in un momento storico
come questo e noi magari lo sappiamo
anche meglio di altri in cui per
determinati settori i mercati sono
saturi questo rappresenta uno degli
scenari più interessanti del prossimo
futuro e non è un caso che alcune fra le
aziende più d'avanguardia quelle più di
frontiera si siano avvicinate a questa
prospettiva quindi qui tecnicamente non
è tanto in gioco in se questo scenario
si verificherà mai il come si
verificherà la risposta che viene data
dal business inclusivo è così ripartita
dunque si parte con un'analisi dei
bisogni per cercare di capire cosa serve
e come serve in questa realtà si
risponde con un bene o con un servizio
che viene pensato per rimanere in questi
mercati quindi essere in linea con un
potere d'acquisto di queste comunità
quindi avere un prezzo che possa essere
accessibile il tutto ragionando con dei
materiali e dei volumi tali da non
generare un tracollo ecologico su scala
globale perché poi questi mercati sono
enormi sono molto molto popolosi
detto questo cosa c'entro io in tutto
questo centro perché nel 2009 mi trovavo
a v per tale in germania per ricerca e
per caso un giorno leggo il primo
articolo che apre la strada di questo di
questo nuovo campo di questo nuovo
settore e li resto veramente affascinata
da questa
potenziale quadratura del cerchio fra
aspetto sociale quindi sviluppo umano
fra green economy elemento profit e così
decido di continuare a seguire un po
questa materia e iscrivermi a vari
convegni che in quel periodo si tenevano
soprattutto in olanda
lì mi rendo conto subito del
consolidarsi di un network cioè di una
rete di attori fatta da professori
consulenti imprenditori del nord e del
sud del mondo
tutti convinti che l'elemento profit
cioè l'azienda cioè l'imprenditore abbia
veramente qualcosa da dire a livello di
sviluppo umano
purché si allontani da un'ottica che
quella che genericamente viene definita
west news best che anche qui si sa
soprattutto in queste comunità a basso
reddito ha fatto molti danni
una delle cose che mi salta subito
all'occhio però è che in questo network
manca il rappresentante italiano cioè
non c'è nessun ente accreditato per
rappresentare la nostra prospettiva
all'interno di questo network e li
decido che quella sarà la mia missione
cioè quello sarà il problema di cui
innamorarsi e quindi decido di di
continuare a seguire questo tema e
continuare a investire in formazione e
mi sposto a londra che non c'entra molto
prendo noce di cocco ma il senso è che
lì continua approfondire il tema ed
entrò in contatto con alcuni casi studio
con alcuni imprenditori molto molto
interessanti come quello che nelle
filippine aiutate da un pool di esperti
di business inclusivo ha inventato
insieme a delle comunità locali delle
filippine dei macchinari per la
lavorazione delle fibre esterne dei
gusci delle noci di cocco queste fibre
venivano poi date da intrecciare a 6000
famiglie locali delle filippine povere
che ottenevano in cambio un inserimento
lavorativo perché venivano pagate ne
derivavano delle reti utilizzate per il
contenimento dei terreni franosi in zone
ad alto rischio sempre delle filippine
cosa avevano di speciale queste reti
intanto era un rifiuto naturale quindi
sostituivano quelle che conosciamo anche
noi di plastica o di metallo
secondo favorivano la riforestazione di
queste zone ad alto rischio quindi un
vantaggio sociale di inserimento
lavorativo 1 ambientale ma anche uno
profit perché poi presterete venivano
vendute in questi mercati quindi erano
pensate per rimanere all'interno di un
prezzo appunto accessibile
ecco quindi il superamento della logica
della gratuità della filantropia che
invece caratterizza la cooperazione allo
sviluppo o l'assistenza allo sviluppo
scalabilità di questo progetto enorme
tanto che adesso è utilizzato in cina
applicato meglio in cina per prevenire
la desertificazione nell'area dei gobi
quindi win win win ok
finita questa esperienza londinese mi
sposto a berlino e lì faccio un po di
bottega nel senso che mi ospita il
laboratorio tedesco
che segue questi temi ciò che segue il
business inclusivo e lì mi accorgo
fortemente dell'importanza del gioco di
squadra cioè del fatto che un esperto di
business inclusivo debba lavorare in un
team in maniera tale da ottimizzare il
processo di dialogo fra le necessità
pragmatica e dell'impresa
dell'imprenditore e le caratteristiche
le preferenze di queste comunità a basso
reddito
a quel punto torna in italia e decide
che è il momento di partire però mi
serve un team quindi mi guardo un po
indietro e
guardando agli anni universitari alle
persone con cui avevo studiato trovo
cinque ragazze sono due ragazze italiane
tre ragazze straniere un'indiana una
vietnamita e una tedesca e quindi siamo
anche noi stessi un po inclusive e
quindi con loro decido di partire con
questa con questa idea con l'idea di
fondare un centro che rappresenta
appunto l'italia all'interno di questa
nuova di questo nuovo campo di questa
nuova disciplina e così nel marzo del
2013 nasce the lab development lab
lavoriamo in pratica come delle cinghie
di trasmissione fra le necessità del
profit e le caratteristiche di queste
comunità a basso reddito e se volete è
un po come parlare tre lingue cioè un po
come parlare profit è un po come parlare
green ed è un po come parlare social e
vi assicuro che spesso non è non è
facilissimo farsi farsi capire
è un po come essere sempre al confine
fra economia e sociologia fra ricerca e
applicazione
nel novembre del 2013 a san paolo in
brasile dell'esrb ottiene
l'accreditamento ufficiale per
rappresentare l'italia come focal point
italiano all'interno di questo network
internazionale di laboratori che
sviluppano che che applicano anche
queste questi nuovi modelli di business
in queste comunità a basso reddito
quindi quella famosa bandierina che
volevo mettere nel 2009 adesso
finalmente c'è quindi la nostra
prospettiva c'è
io sono veramente convinta che il
business inclusivo e non sia un nome
trendy
nuovo applicato su un concetto vecchio
su un concetto già sperimentato sono
davvero convinta che sia uno degli
scenari più interessanti del prossimo
futuro in cui gli imprenditori saranno
tenuti a ragionare in questi prossimi
anni e sono anche convinta che dia dei
risultati positivi non soltanto lì dove
applicato ma anche a livello sistemico
cioè aprendo veramente delle nuove delle
nuove strade
quando tutto questo sarà diciamo la
regola
non più l'eccezione quando verrà
applicato il business inclusivo di
default ok anche quando una persona
fermata per strada a caso in qualunque
posto del mondo commenterà dicendo
asuncion ok cioè le stesse cose le
sappiamo le queste cose si sanno beh
allora noi li avremmo dimostrato tre
cose la prima è che il confine fra
profit e non profit non è così netto
come noi lo pensiamo
la seconda è che non bisogna per forza
essere dei laureati delle università
della ivy league americane o venire da
un paese molto freddo e molto al nord
per fare innovazione
ma c'è un innovazione che parte dal
basso da queste comunità che vale la
pena di capire e studiare
e la terza è che se noi vogliamo porci
di fronte alle sfide future agli scenari
futuri
a livello globale in maniera razionale
beh allora noi dobbiamo sicuramente
avere del pensiero laterale però poi
bisogna anche essere consapevoli di
questi nuovi modelli credere in queste
nuove idee e fidarsi di queste nuove
vedute
e questo ad oggi a mio avviso resta la
sfida più importante
grazie